hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy and i just want to remind
everyone that as we're going through
what's clearly a very difficult time
especially well in the world generally
but especially in education that the
entire team here at khan academy is
dedicated to making sure that teachers
and parents and students feel and are as
supported as possible but i also like to
remind everyone that we're not for
profit and we can only exist because of
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you believe in a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere which i think is more relevant
than ever please think about making a
donation to khan academy we were running
at a deficit even before the coveted
crisis hit and you can imagine once the
crisis hit our traffic has been two to
three x of what it typically is our
registrations are 10 to 20 x of normal
and we're trying to accelerate a whole
series of programs not only support
supporting the server load we've
accelerated get ready for grade level
courses which makes sure that students
around the world have the ability to
fill in any gaps they need so they're
optimally ready to learn at their own
time and pace at grade level we're
trying to support teachers and parents
with webinars
students with as many supports that we
can provide them but all of this is only
possible if we have donations from folks
like yourself so if you're in a position
to do so please think about making a
donation to khan academy thank you
you